bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin sur arte france
d'abord pour bien comprendre la
situation du g5 sahel quelle est sa
capacité aujourd'hui à réagir face à la
menace jihadiste dans la région bon
c'est un groupement de cinq armées
nationales sur la zone qui a été monté
il ya quelques années qui a encore
beaucoup de difficultés à monter en
gamme
donc il ya eu quelques opérations
conjointes mais c'est pas encore ça donc
pour l'instant il ya toujours des
défaillances qui effectivement souligne
que bah c'est quand même la france qui
reste le maître d'oeuvre de cette
architecture sécuritaire dans la zone
alors justement sur les défaillances les
problèmes d'opérationnalisation du g5
sahel depuis le montage en fait de cette
force qui regroupe plusieurs pays du
sahel on voit qu'on sait très difficile
notamment sur le plan des ressources
humaines mais aussi financière laquelle
est la responsabilité par exemple d'un
pays comme la france c'est à dire que la
ja il ya la volonté de la france de
vouloir un peu mutualiser les moyens que
les impurs les européens s'appelait plus
donc elle cette force takouba qui a été
montée maintenant je suis pas sûr que
des suédois ou des estoniens qui sont
pas vraiment réputé connaître la zone
feront vraiment bouger les lignes que ça
permettra vraiment de de monter en
puissance qu'on sait c'est que depuis le
début de l'intervention militaire de la
france en 2013
les groupes jihadistes sont toujours
actifs ils se sont même étendues donc de
ce point de vue on a vraiment un
sentiment d' enlisement d'ensablement
dans cette zone du monde où finalement
la menace n'a pas du tout disparu elle
même plutôt tendance à augmenter
donc ça soulève de sérieuses questions
sur la prolongation de l'engagement
militaire des intervenants étrangers au
premier rang desquels évidemment la
france n'est pas seulement il ya aussi
les casques bleus des nations unies ne
les oublions pas se pose évidemment
énormément de
de problème de coordination certains
parlent d'ailleurs de nos bouteilles âge
sécuritaire dans la zone parce qu'on
voit vraiment un empilement en fait de
deux forces armées qui interviennent et
qui se coordonnent pas forcément très
très bien entraîne donc dont la
taskforce takouba initiée au niveau
européen qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur
cette force vient tout juste de démarrer
donc c'est un petit peu trop tôt pour
démarrer un bilan disons que ça c'est
encore un empilement dans cette dans cet
embouteillage sécuritaire une force
supplémentaire donc à chaque fois ça
veut dire des problèmes de coordination
donc il ya des problèmes de coordination
à l'intérieur du g5 sahel entre le g5
sahel et l'armée française et puis
maintenant il ya takouba je pense que de
toute façon le fond du problème il est
politique beaucoup plus que militaire
c'est-à-dire que les états de la zone
notamment le mali mais aussi le burkina
sont défaillants donc on peut toujours
réfléchir en termes militaires mais
c'est absolument pas suffisant les
armées nationales sont défaillantes
elles ont commis aussi des exactions
pour certaines d'entre elles qui en fait
entretenu le conflit donc aujourd'hui
tout ceci n'est absolument pas résolu
regarder la situation au mali où les
militaires viennent de commettre un
putsch on a vraiment le sentiment très
désagréable de revenir à la situation de
quand en fait l'armée malienne étaient
davantage préoccupés à se partager les
préventes du pouvoir à bamako plutôt
qu'à combattre dans le nord les groupes
jihadistes et là avec le putsch à bamako
on a vraiment l'impression de revenir
finalement au début de l'intervention
militaire française en 2013 en janvier
des maîtresses et sur la question du
désengagement militaire français au
sahel qui inquiètent visiblement le
commandement du budget 5
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire quelle est la
position à ce que la position de la
france elle est clair parce qu'on sait
que les militaires français ils ont
quand même obtenu des résultats dans
leur lutte contre le djihadisme
notamment au mali fin dans cette région
la position française n'est pas vraiment
clair qu'il ya sûrement diplomatie dans
les coulisses qui ce qui se joue y
compris sur des exigences canton quant à
l'amélioration des performances
militaires locales
y compris d'ailleurs sur l'utilisation
de milices ans qui est extrêmement
dangereux que ce qu'on voit un peu une
déliquescence du monopole la sécurité
qui est censé exercer les états dans la
zone
donc elle sûrement beaucoup de
négociations en coulisses puisque vous
rappelez il y avait aussi des
manifestations anti françaises dans la
zone notamment à bamako mais également à
ouagadougou
donc il ya sûrement des négociations par
derrière on imagine bien que la volonté
de la france et de se désengager ce cas
une opération qui coûte au bas mot 1
milliard d'euros par an maintenant la
question c'est de voir dans quelle
mesure c'est possible de le faire sans
trop perdre la face puisque je vous le
disais les groupes djihadistes perdure
et en même plutôt tendance à se
rapprocher de bamako ont signalé la
semaine dernière des d44 de l'état
islamique au conte sahara qui était à
moins de 100 km de bamako
quand la france était intervenue à
l'époque les groupes djihadistes était
sur une distance dix fois supérieur donc
par rapport à la capitale donc il ya
vraiment des questions qui se posent sur
l' architecture sécuritaire qui est en
train de se mettre en place dans la zone
et sur la capacité des états de la zone
vraiment à répondre à cette menace
notamment pour ce qui est de l'impunité
de leurs forces de sécurité qui à mon
avis va pas du tout dans le bon sens
puisque quand des massacres sont commis
ça va plutôt légitime et les groupes
djihadistes qui apparaissent du coup
comme des forces de résistance et ça va
au contraire délégitimer les états et
cette question de l'impunité des forces
de sécurité n'est absolument pas résolu
pour l'instant et quand vous parlez de
négociation tout à l'heure ça veut dire
que la réponse allait pas seulement
militaire je pense qu'il ya des
négociations d'un arrière puisque je
suis quand même assez convaincu que la
france souhaiterait se désengager au
moins sur le plan sur le plan militaire
maintenant comment le faire concrètement
comment passer le relais à désarmer
locales qui sont déficientes qui repose
trop souvent sur des milices qui elle
met comme qui a elle-même commet des
exactions
voyez si la france se désengager paix
que la situation se détériore gravement
sur la zone
ça serait vraiment un échec ce serait
perçu comme tel
donc je pense qu'il ya des il ya des
négociations avec la perspective d'un
désengagement mais qui se ferait en
quelque sorte dans l'honneur sans que la
situation se dégrade trop rapidement sur
le terrain
merci beaucoup à vous marc antoine
pérouse de montclos je rappelle que vous
êtes le directeur de recherche à
l'institut de recherche pour le
développement